[Music]
would you guys consider yourselves to be
generous nope yes oh generous no uh how
much did i drink
i hope so what do you mean by generous
stuff or do we just consider ourselves
to be generous
people call me generous but i'm like i'm
not
because i feel like i could be even more
generous but i'm not
so it's like maybe to their standards
i'm generous
because they're greedy bastards but then
for me i'm like
i could be even more generous but i'm
holding back i'm generous with what
money all right oh just your time
my time i would say for sure with time
i'm stingy as [ __ ] he is money i'm very
generous
true no time is part of it yes very
sensitive with time
oh yeah very good with our love
languages and the way we communicate
no more like more like time and money
i'm pretty generous with dick pics i
don't charge
that's cool i just sometimes send it you
could be making so much money
i know but i i feel like
i can't yeah it's
because it's like art you know like you
can't taint your art by
making it a business know except artists
i'm passionate how do you explain jk
this is different oh
yeah got you it's got you okay all right
anyway i'm not that passionate about it
oh okay
it's not it's not like sacred like my
dick pics that's a
that's a talent that i'm never gonna
just sell good good for you joe
but um but yeah so there's this study
here that
they this new research paper has found
that there is a linear relationship
between the amount of
amount and frequency of wealth transfers
and a person's life expectancy
so they're saying that generous people
tend to live
longer yeah yeah that makes sense with
time or money
both then it just
cancels out but you know what it seems
to be that they're
actually looking more of wealth
transfers is how they're putting it like
the wording
that they're using generous with food
yeah joe just bought me a spicy tuna
roll so
did he buy it for you or is it one of
those where he didn't want it
no i requested it i ordered it i ordered
it but he paid
he's gonna get his leftovers he's like
hey does anyone want this i don't want
it anymore
that's still generosity it could go in
the trash
easily i could save it for later because
i eat leftovers
or that he could save it for himself
i'll give it to you that's generous
well yes i brought donuts that i didn't
finish yesterday the leftovers everybody
wants some day-old donuts
and it's still good so he offered it
first and then
he took a bite and goes okay i guess
it's still good why are half of them
upside down
did you like it fell that way oh
i'm down take that coconut one take it
save it for me
it's the last right side open you better
eat it fast before it becomes two day
old donuts
true three so wealth transfer that
it's technically just money that's what
it sounds like yeah but they did
so the more money that you give over
time
then your life becomes longer that's
what this research is okay so to break
it down correlation i guess we're saying
that
individuals are reportedly shared
between
68 to 69 of their lifetime
income while uh they were recording
mortality rates about twice as low as
those
in china and turkey where citizens
shared between
44 to 48 of their lifetime earnings well
that's not fair they ain't got no money
to share
well yeah so then those in south
american countries
they were also found to rank highly in
terms of generosity sharing more than 60
of an average person's lifetime income
but
countries like sub-saharan saharan
africa and southeast asia they were
found to be
at the lower end of the spectrum with
people experiencing
shorter life spans where they are being
the least able to share
portions of their earnings i wonder if
sharing earnings has anything to do with
your health
i don't think so no it does so yes so i
don't share over 60 percent
that's for sure what is the lifetime
what does the average person
give because maybe we're just not aware
of of how much we get because i feel
like maybe in these countries the health
standards are lower that's why they die
faster
not because they don't share well it's
the the fact that they're saying is that
there's a correlation with countries um
of like the with the presence of
financial transfers
exhibiting greater social cohesion so
they feel more
part of their community i see when
they're more generous
and then that leads to healthier bodies
healthier more social responsibility to
each other
exactly so that's cool where it's
ingrained in the culture to be sharing
yeah when i get a bunch of bananas i go
you guys want a banana
that's interesting that asia's part of
that or like china specifically is part
of that because i thought it was more of
a collectivist
china don't share it it seems like
rather than just
also saying because the individual
person person's sharing that they're
doing better in life it also sounds like
just because everybody's sharing so
maybe when you're
down in the dumps somebody else is
picking you back up that's what it
sounds like yeah so it's not because
it's not so much as an individual
sharing more so we just did that it
wouldn't really make a difference
but if the entire community is doing
that then anytime they're feeling sick
or whatever and they can't work somebody
else can take care of them while
they're sick at home there's more of a
social support in some cultures
um so because it's like for example
in america i think america the best
example might be
hawaii where they um
they have that ohana mindset where
everything is like kind of family style
like when you bring food you bring it to
your neighbors too you bring you just
constantly share stuff yeah and you
don't feel like they owe you
for you even doing no you just kind of
yeah everyone has surplus they give
right
and then that's why during the pandemic
when a lot of the tourists were hoarding
toilet paper it was so against the
culture that they're like the [ __ ]
why yeah it's hella selfish but in
mainland america like
everyone's more selfish especially in
the big cities
like they're like it's it's all about me
you know yep survival yeah it is
survival even the driving style the
surplus of
things that we could live off of yeah
like the [ __ ]
you need the first thing you talk you
think about survival is wiping your ass
you got your priorities all [ __ ] up
man
yeah so they were mentioning that those
in western europe and japan
were found to rank the highest on data
linking resource sharing
and lower levels of mortality and
demonstrated the highest average
individual wealth transfer so they're
more giving so another part of this it's
in the culture too yeah where's the u.s
low on the list yeah
so they're saying that uh resource
sharing has always been a central
component
component of human sociality
children require heavy investments in
human capital during working years
help is needed due to illness disability
or bad luck while hunter gatherer elders
assisted their descendants more recent
more recently elderly withdrawn from
work and require assistance as well
willingness
willingly willingness to share has been
critically important for our past
evolutionary success in our present
daily lives
so their findings from 34 countries on
on six continents suggest that survival
is higher in societies that provide more
support and care for one another
so that's why they tend to live longer
hmm that's true
it does feel good when everyone like
cares about each other
really does and when we used to live in
monterey park like we really got to know
our neighbors and it was really cool
and we had like an extra mattress and we
gave it to
one of the grandmas and then like if
they had extra fruits
they would just bring it over so even
when you're living inside your own house
it just felt good knowing that oh cool
my neighbors care about me and i care
about them yeah that's true
but this is the first home that i live
in that i've ever felt that
like i've never felt connected to my
neighbors yeah i've never felt a sense
of community really
um with people that i live near
it's usually my family or my friends
whatever is when i feel that
but in this community it does feel like
that it feels like we all got our backs
like um one of my neighbors was texting
me a while back that my garage door was
open i was like thanks
and then like we're texting the other
neighbor that um they had left something
out and then
it's just like we always we all got our
back each other's backs and it just
feels really nice because i've never
felt that before
yeah i feel like that this study does
make sense i mean it could be
coincidence
or not you know but like i think
you can really dance then um
i feel like that the happier you are
as a person and yeah you sharing your
wealth and stuff you know the less
i mean in an ideal world you know you're
not manifesting anything that will get
you sick
you know that will make you possibly
depressed or anything like that if
you're kind of living your best life
and um in giving you know
doing what you can i try to share my
dick but some people would say that's
offensive
have you seen your dick yeah i have
were you offended no oh okay have you
ever seen it erect
no that's a good sign that's a good
that's real friendship
be weird i'm never in that environment
where it is right like
joe why are you erect right now
i like how come he can't come come calm
here
why are you erect right now that could
happen because i just recently learned
some scientific [ __ ] called
arousal non-concordance no reason boners
[ __ ] blew my mind
that both women and men uh go through so
for men
it's about a 60 overlap where your brain
is turned on and your body responds to
that by
you know either getting wet or having a
boner sixty percent overlap for men
what's overlapping uh meaning that that
uh
if my brain is horny and for sure
so sixty percent it's synced up the
other 40 is not synced up yes exactly
and for women it's the opposite it's 40
it is synced up
60 it isn't that's why when like when
women are like oh i'm so turned on right
now and then they're not wet
or roused on concordance so what's the
non-synced
part and you're just like wet most of
the time for non-horny reasons
uh it's not about most of the time it's
just like if if
like uh okay so there's this one when
it's supposed to or not supposed to be
is because um your body your body
is reacting to something that is known
to be erotic sometimes
so there's this one example because i'm
reading this book and that's how i know
this
so in the it's called come as you are
super highly recommend it okay
so in this book she's talking about this
one story how a
a friend of hers told her how her
boyfriend
like they were trying some kinky [ __ ] he
tied her up on like with her hands up
and then she was naked and then he left
a broomstick in between her legs for her
to hold
and then he left pretty hot and then she
was just like you know what
not really about this i'm kind of bored
like where is he is that a sign to do
the chores later
you know what to do with this girl he
saw
dusty the floor was but uh and then so
when he came back
he told oh she told him like i'm not
really turned on like this ain't this is
not doing it for me
and then he's like well then why are you
so hap so wet
and so that's like her body was reacting
to something like her body was horny but
her brain wasn't horny
exactly her brain was thinking about i
want some
dessert right now yeah or she probably
started thinking about how dirty the
floors were she's like [ __ ] he
is right oh my god so did she get her
two toes like this and with the
broomstick started [ __ ] cleaning it
up
while she's tied up like this yeah she's
all like like in fantasia
oh god
[Music]
we gotta cut it we gotta cut it
you